- ALL RIGHT,
SO WE HAVE TO REMEMBER H5.
- OKAY. UH, OH.
I GOT IT. HIGH FIVE.
- OH, I SEE. OH, THAT'S GOOD.
I SEE WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO THERE.
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
A MNEMONIC DEVICE.
- YEAH, TRYING.
- HIGH FIVES
CAME OUT IN THE '70s.
THAT'S WHEN THEY WERE INVENTED,
THAT'S A 7.
- YEAH.
- THERE'S TWO OF US.
- SO WHY ARE YOU--
- SO IF YOU SUBTRACT 2 FROM 7,
THAT'S 5.
- OKAY, GREAT. SO YOU GOT IT.
SO UM...
- AND THEN, UM,
THERE'S FIVE MAJOR FOOD GROUPS.
- WHY ARE YOU GOING ON?
- OH, NO.
YOU'RE GONNA LOVE THIS.
THIS IS FUN FOR ME
'CAUSE IT'S A PUZZLE.
- NO PUZZLE.
- FIVE MAJOR FOOD GROUPS.
THERE IS MEAT, VEGETABLES,
GRAIN, DAIRY, AND FRUIT.
- OH. MY GOD.
OKAY.
- MY FAVORITE FRUIT
IS PINEAPPLE.
- BUT YOU KNOW THAT
WE GOT IT ALREADY, SO...
- PINEAPPLE COMES FROM HAWAII.
- OKAY.
- AND OH, OH,
MY FAVORITE CURRENT SHOW
IS HAWAII FIVE-0.
- HAWAII FIVE-0.
OKAY, SO THAT'S IT. DONE.
WE'RE DONE. HAWAII FIVE-0.
- YEAH.
OOH, OOH, AND SCOTT CAAN
IS THE START OF HAWAII FIVE-0.
- SCOTT CAAN? WE'RE REALLY
TALKING ABOUT SCOTT CAAN NOW?
- AND HIS FATHER IS JAMES CAAN,
WHO'S ONE OF
THE FIVE MAJOR STARS OF THE--
- WHAT'S WRONG WITH YOU?
- ONE OF THE FIVE MAJOR
HUGE STARS, "H," RIGHT?
OF THE GODFATHER MOVIES.
SO IT'S CAAN, PACINO,
BRANDO, DUVALL, AND UM...
- I DON'T EVEN KNOW
WHY YOU'RE DOING THIS.
- OH...
- DIANE KEATON.
- DIANE KEATON, YES. THANK YOU.
AND IT'S EASY TO REMEMBER
HER NAME 'CAUSE HER NAME
IS THE SAME LAST NAME AS BUSTER
KEATON AND MICHAEL KEATON.
- BUT--NO--OKAY. WE'RE JUST
GOING THROUGH THIS NOW.
- BOTH COMEDIANS,
AND WHEN YOU LAUGH,
YOU SAY "HA."
- STOP.
STOP.
- "HA-HA."
- STOP. STOP.
STOP! STOP!
YOU SEE WHAT YOU'RE DOING?
YOU'RE OVERCOMPLICATING
THE WHOLE THING.
WE ALREADY HAD IT.
YOU'RE JUST MAKING
IT MORE DIFFICULT,
JUST LIKE YOU DO EVERYTHING.
I LEFT MY PHONE IN THE CAR.
WHICH...IS...WAIT, HOLD UP.
A DAP...NO, IT WAS HANDSHAKE...
- NO, I GOT IT.
I GOT IT. I GOT IT. HA.
BUSTER KEATON AND MICHAEL KEATON
HAVE THE SAME LAST NAME
AS DIANE KEATON
WHO'S ONE OF THE FIVE HUGE STARS
ON THE GODFATHER MOVIES...
- NO. NO--NO--NO.
BUT I GOT IT.
- IT'S KEATON, BRANDO,
DUVALL, PACINO,
AND JAMES CAAN...
- OH, OKAY.
- WHO'S THE FATHER
OF SCOTT CAAN,
WHO'S THE STAR OF HAWAII FIVE-0.
HAWAII, PINEAPPLE,
PINEAPPLE'S MY FAVORITE FRUIT...
- NO--NO--NO--NO--NO--NO.
- FIVE MAJOR FOOD GROUPS...
- NO, YOU CAN'T--
- THERE'S TWO OF US.
5 PLUS 2 IS 7...
- WAIT, WAIT...SO...
- THAT'S THE '70s WHEN
HIGH FIVES WERE INVENTED, H-5.
- HIGH FIVE! HIGH FIVE!
I HAD IT!
DAMN!